En France, une grossesse sur quatre est
une fausse couche
et une femme sur dix,
au cours de sa vie vit une fausse couche.
La fausse couche est un phénomène naturel,
qui peut être vécu difficilement
pour les femmes et pour les couples.
Il faut savoir que les femmes
et les couples
qui ont des difficultés
à vivre l'épreuve de la fausse couche
ont des symptômes
de dépression, d'angoisse.
Si l'accompagnement psychologique
fait défaut.
Je suis ravie de porter cette proposition de loi
au nom du MoDem, au nom de la politique sociétale,
une politique familiale pour l'accompagnement
des femmes et des couples.
Le fond de cette proposition de loi
est de proposer un parcours
“fausse couche” sur tous les territoires
de France et d'Outre-mer, en lien
avec les agences régionales de santé,
afin de déployer un vrai réseau
de professionnels, de les former
et de permettre,
aux personnes qui le souhaitent,
aux femmes et aux couples, d'être
vraiment accompagnés psychologiquement
suite à une fausse couche.
La femme vit au cours de sa vie
plusieurs changements,
parfois certaines épreuves,
la fausse couche en est une,
dont l'accompagnement psychologique
est important
pour lui permettre, si elle le souhaite,
d'être mieux accompagnée
et de mieux vivre cette épreuve
qui parfois peut aussi toucher le couple.
C'est pour ça que la proposition de loi
vise à l'accompagnement psychologique
des couples victimes de fausse
couche.
Aussi, on peut imaginer aujourd’hui,
quand, par exemple,
une femme vit une fausse couche,
elle peut demander un arrêt maladie
et le gouvernement souhaite lever
le jour de carence, c'est-à-dire que
la femme pourra prendre son arrêt maladie
sans subir ce jour de carence.
Pour le 8 mars,
c'est aussi un bon point pour ce qui concerne
l'évolution des droits des femmes.